endlich mal ein bisschen zeit für mich
das habe ich mir auch verdient nach den
letzten tagen und als letzten schritt
benutze ich den glory den benutze ich
schon lange denn er ist nicht nur lernt
und beruhigen sondern hat auch einen
slow aging effekt unglaublich wie meine
haut danach strahlt zum glück hatte ich
den rabattcode mal wanne korea mit dem
ihr euch jetzt auch noch die jäger skin
care produkte mit 30 prozent rabatt
sichern könnten mit einem
mindestbestellwert von 69 euro sogar
eine jeder kern visbeck dazu
ich liebe korea
[Musik]
aber wir sind wir überhaupt hierher
gekommen
rund eine stunde
meiner besseren hälfte und 22 kilo im
gepäck machten wir uns auf dem weg zum
flughafen geht los
naja fast
[Musik]
40 kilometer entfernt vom park
zum glück habe ich so viel anxiety vor
dem zu spät kommt dass wir so früh los
sind dass es alles noch geklappt hat
angst kann auch geil sein den jobcentern
vor uns lag 1 15 stunden flug mit
zwischenstopp in istanbul
die und wie ihr seht ist der flughafen
istanbul einfach nur atem und da ging es
auch schon ins nächste flugzeug eine
boeing
777 white glaub ich und schon sind wir
gelandet und wurden ganz herzlich von
yakuza begrüßt
die werden wir jetzt die nächsten tage
verbringen
und uns richtig gut gehen lassen ich bin
so kaputt
ich glaube ich nicht dass ich gar nicht
fast gar nicht gibt im flieger fast gar
nicht kennt
[Musik]
hier also hier haben wir das bett schön
die couch und finde es toll dass du auch
eine mütze bekommen das team und auch
einen gesichtsschleier von epo oder das
ist falls die nächsten tage wird zu heiß
hier kannst du
ja und da tritt ich
ihr neues produkt ja das habe ich auch
erwartet
und jetzt kommen wir an was ein
badezimmer sehr sehr schön aber da muss
man sich als paar auch richtig obwohl
timo
ziemlich verdunkelt oder war das was du
da meint ist der schalter für die
spieler für diese mit hydro pumpe in
einem profi
[Applaus]
ich muss ja mal richtig gut verstehen
dass man dass man sagt so ich bin jetzt
auf glück ja das war's mit dem
hotelzimmer wie geht das essen und dann
oh hallo willkommen zu tag eins in korea
gestern um 18 uhr sind wir angekommen
haben noch was gegessen jetzt sind wir
ausgeschlafen und fit für den ersten tag
mich jetzt nicht nur mich das sind die
produktions stelle entwicklungsstelle
also dort groß
entwickelt wird produziert wird ich weiß
auch von mir phase viele creator wurden
von ihr bruder nach korea eingeladen und
da wollten sie natürlich nicht die
chance verpassen uns die
produktionsstätte zu zeigen angekommen
wurden wir nach südkoreanische art
herzlichste begrüßt und es wurden sogar
traditionelle koreanische snacks für uns
vorbereitet
karmann empfehlen nica die mitgründerin
hat uns von der geschichte von ihrer
mutter erzählt und was alles dahinter
steckt so ein produkt auf den markt zu
bringen ab oder hat sich nämlich zur
aufgabe gemacht klassisch koreanische
skincare mit den anforderungen an sich
selbst zu verbinden und die
anforderungen sind hoch und dadurch auch
die entwicklungszeit dementsprechend
lang aber es lohnt sich denn die
produkte sind wirklich
einmal in aktion gesehen und jan
arbeitet auch bei ihr bruder und hat uns
über die zeit betreut hier erklärte sie
uns gerade den ablauf der abfüllung und
verpackung so
unglaublich service feilen hier seht ihr
übrigens den mist helfen toner der eure
haut perfekt für weitere pflegeprodukte
vorbereitet
danach wurden die sechs mit einer
überraschung verteilt
dessen geheim zurück das sind produkte
die po dabei veröffentlichen wird und
die wir schon mal testen dürfen
[Musik]
und vom produktionsteam gab es noch eine
schöne stadt ohne
[Musik]
geschenke abgestaubt und habe eine ganz
wichtige sache gelernt es läuft nicht
wie bruder sondern jetzt das heißt es
schön macht drin
jetzt gehen wir weiter zum
buddhistischen essen kann 10 11
mein absolutes highlight waren diese
reise brüssel in denen einfach
durchgängig kate ob videos liefen in
diesem buddhistischen restaurant war
alles total klein und verwinkelt und
alles war voll mit pflanzen und sogar
ein vogel war da und man hatte gar nicht
das gefühl in einem restaurant zu sein
sondern er in so einem kleinen tempel
und das war ja auch das thema das
restaurant das essen war auf jeden fall
eine interessante erfahrung kann man auf
jeden fall machen es war jetzt aber
nicht so mein fall willkommen hier am
hafen wir gehen jetzt auf meine ja und
das machen wir jetzt einfach mal und
jetzt folgen coole jetzt aufnahmen
was soll ich sagen leute wir waren
einfach auf einem boot und eigentlich
sollte es regnen und dann hat aber doch
plötzlich nicht gerecht wird und die
sonne schien und wir waren perfekt zum
sonnenuntergang da also die perfekte
stimmung für eine bootstour
sonnenuntergang essen korea sie sehnt
influenza ihren social content
produzieren
ist ein seltenes später treffen sie sind
live dabei
da hat sich eine gruppe zusammengetan
man sieht also influenza sind
herdentiere und damit zurück
kühlen schnitten ich kenne ja schon die
bootsfahrt auf der spree durch berlin
aber das war noch mal ein ganz anderes
level die skyline vom fluss aus zu sehen
war so atemberaubend schön
es war auf jeden fall der perfekte
ausklang für den ersten tag es war eine
ausgelassene stimmung und ich glaube wir
waren alle sehr sehr hart und wir hatten
sogar die chance die rainbow bridge vom
wasser aus zu sehen aber das war erstmal
genug für tag 1
wir sind hier mit dem bruder auf dem
flugmarkt ja wir machen mit dem kochkurs
wird ganz toll unsere kosten auf jeden
fall
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist übrigens jung hielt sie für den
kochkurs hell ok cooking und zu ihrem
kochkurs gehört es dazu die teilnehmer
vorher auf den markt herum zu führen sie
zeigt uns in verschiedenen lebensmitteln
die essens kultur von korea und viele
kleine infos die man so privat nie auf
dem markt erkennen würde
und danach ging es weiter zum kochen was
übrigens bei jung hier zu hause war also
bekamen wir einen richtigen eindruck von
einer großstadt wohnung in seoul
wir sind jetzt bei dem kochkurs es ist
das erste mal dass ich einen kochkurs
mache also wusste ich gar nicht was mich
erwartet
die aufgaben die man bekommt sind
relativ simpel also kann auch ein
anfänger mit max kleine alchemisten
aber trotzdem lernt man richtig gut die
abläufe für ein gericht
hey
du
hast
du mich war vielen teil des wave juni
war wirklich obst essen ist dass wir den
pancake flippen müssen und sie macht von
jeder gruppe ein video also bitteschön
vorbei
[Musik]
barbara
juni
wir haben die bakterien pancakes und
schicken gemacht und es war sooo lecker
und mein gott ich muss es zu hause
unbedingt wieder ausprobieren zum
abschluss gab es noch eine runde
macaulay das ist reiswein der in
anschein serviert wird und nachdem wir
uns kurz von unserem food koma erholt
haben ging es wieder zum es
auf meinem kanal ist es kein geheimnis
mehr dass ich kurian barbecue liebe für
alle die aber immer noch nicht wissen
was es in der mitte des tisches gibt es
einen grill und auf dem wildfleisch
gebracht dann hat man noch ein paar
beilagen und wie beim raclette wird
einfach so am tisch gebraten gegessen
und sich gefreut
[Musik]
diese
40 15
januar
eins kann ich jetzt immer prophet sein
ich werde nicht nur mit mehr gepäck in
meinen koffer zurückkommen
[Musik]
und nun geht es mit dem weiter wofür wir
nach korea geflogen sind beauty
cosmetics ist ein dermatologe studio was
auch kay popstars behandelt also müssen
sie gut sein hier wurden futuristische
koreanische anwendungs methoden mit den
produkten von joop oder verbunden um so
die perfekte symbiose zwischen beiden
komponenten zu erschaffen aber das wird
ein eigenes video deswegen war das jetzt
alles und der beauty tag sollte hier
aber noch nicht vorbei sein wir waren in
einem beauty café in korea gibt es cafés
mit verschiedenen themen und hier kann
man sich stylen schminken produkte
kaufen und dabei einen kaffee trinken
und einen rainbow cache ist und wenn der
tag schon mal unter dem thema beauty
steht sollte auch eine neue frisur her
[Musik]
du musst von hinten ich hatte keine
direkte vorstellung was ich möchte ich
habe nur ein paar bilder gezeigt und
wusste dass die kaputten spitzen ab
müssen dann hatte ich noch drei
verschiedene haarfarben die auf jeden
fall korrigiert werden mussten und im
endeffekt habe ich der frisörin
komplette freiheit gelassen und war
gespannt was ich bekomme weil die
verhandlung komplett und weihnachten die
frisur die ich haben möchte ich auch
bekommen ich bin einfach hier rein
gegangen hab gesagt eure haare für alles
klar
es ist auf jeden fall kürzer als ich
erwartet habe aber mir gefällt es
richtig richtig gut wir sind gerade an
so einem brett und hier kann man für
1000 worden seine zukunft vorhergesagt
bekommen und man muss natürlich in dem
ja gucken in dem man geboren wurde ich
wurde im jahr des hahns geboren mal
gucken was meine zukunft reden
[Musik]
ok so folger
kuju
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
entertainment wenn ich den ganzen juni
durch getrunken hat
[Musik]
ich bin ich dadurch berühmt geworden
der action
concept store
space frames gamers treu
neuer tag fast gleiches thema heute
bekommen wir ein cape ob umstyling bei
einem stylisten studio das sich unter
anderem und black pink kümmert
[Musik]
sie sind so ein trauriges vorher wie bei
james ex topmodel bevor sie dann dieses
kraftwerk urkunden
[Musik]
zuerst meine haare gemacht und da hab
ich den stylisten komplette freiheit
gelassen was mir sofort aufgefallen ist
wie filigranen koreanische stylisten
arbeiten für sie ist jede strähne
wichtig die haare sind jetzt fertig
[Musik]
gemacht hierbei macht gesagt mach was du
möchtest köln um uns über auch wieder
super meine haut wurde für das make up
mit dieb oder produkten vorbereitet ich
würde auf dem platz auf dem in prag noch
eine bekannte koreanische schauspielerin
saß ich blende euch hier das bild ein
und wo sie alles mitgespielt hat dabei
ich sage sich zu laut weil ich wenn ich
das höre jetzt auf dem gleichen platz
wie sie gerade eben nicht krasses gefühl
irgendwie hier zu sein um zu wissen dass
es einfach so viele kate und kate's
zum special zuerst kam das mist have ins
spiel was meine haut figuriert und
entspannt danach hat sie eine mischung
aus dem gloria serum und der make my day
cream gemacht und auf meiner haut
aufgetragen das vibriert meiner haut
zusätzlich pflegt sie und lässt sie
strahlen auch bei dem make-up merkt man
dass in korea sehr viel wert auf
feinheiten gelegt wird die augenbrauen
werden ich einfach nur durchgekämmt da
wird jedes haar an den richtigen platz
gebracht
[Musik]
und dann kam auch schon der multi beim
zum einsatz den kann man für mehrere
bereiche einsätzen nicht nur für die
lippen sondern auch pudel wann als blass
und als lidschatten für die augen
der multi baum ist feuchtigkeit spenden
durch shea butter pflegend durch mango
butter und diese versorgt die haut
gleichzeitig mit vitamin e und vitamin c
werden und jetzt seht ihr was ich mit
filigranen meine meine wimpern wurden
nicht nur getäuscht nein auch mit einer
pinzette so zusammengeführt das ist
richtig
[Musik]
ich wurde noch nie so gestylt
die
film
[Musik]
mein gesicht und meine haare waren
einfach perfekt
und wenn man den gang dann schon mal zum
cape of idle umgestylt wird dann müssen
natürlich auch ein paar fotos gemacht
werden und die berühmte library in der
krise eher kleiner trick 17 mit dem
google übersetzer kann man
übersetzen
und dann kann ich mir das in ruhe
durchlesen das ist die sonderausstellung
daten derzeit zum fünften jahrestag der
bibliothek
biologie immer dann wirklich sehr
beeindruckend doch das einzige woran ich
denken musste wer entstaubt dieses regal
eine frau darf natürlich in gang nicht
fehlen die gamestop
am
samstag nummer fünf heute geht es auf
den gesang market und zum palast
und zum x-ten da haben wir zwar schon
einmal aber heute wollen wir uns noch
mal richtig durch findet es wird ein
langer großer tag das kann man sich so
im store mit teils schon drin
getränkt es ist ein getränk oder es ist
dass amerika
[Musik]
sie wissen
ja also die frau bereitet das zu wenn
sie heiratet wir haben den tag der
hochzeit sie machen so einen so table
und dann die frau muss zu jeder familie
mitglieder der des mannes da grünen und
dann so was
das ist so in the dogs brauche ich der
gewann dank market ist ursprünglich
dafür gedacht um alles für die hochzeit
zu finden von den geschenken für den
mann über die inhalte die man in einem
haushalt braucht aber was interessiert
uns natürlich gut also hochzeit ist naja
da warten wir noch wird und wenn jetzt
mehr von dem ganzen food ihr sehen wollt
dazu kommt noch ein extra video da
müsste ich noch ein bisschen gedulden
und ja jetzt lassen wir es gab so viel
leckeres essen auf diesem markt ich halt
nicht aus ich werde davon noch mein
leben lang träumen und wie cool sie
bitte alles aus ich habe das gefühl ich
bin in einem film die stimmung war
wuselig aber mega coup
und jetzt genug mit beauty und es zeit
für kultur also das ist jetzt ein paar
lastwagen und hier hatten könig geburt
ja genau hier hat einen könig gewohnt
unter druck
[Musik]
darauf ist die berufsbezeichnung oder
der name
nein sie müssten ja immer so
auf dem kino so
bisher dann rauskommt sagt nein immer
also
ständig sieht könnten nicht einmal denn
king einfach in den augen gucken müssen
immer so machen also nicht mal so ich
denke also wenn du so koreanische trucks
dann sie sind immer so
südkorea ist zwar mehr bekannt für seine
entertainmentbranche aber die kultur und
geschichte ist genauso spannend und man
konnte mir so viel erzählen über die
entwicklung dieses landes und kommen wir
jetzt von der geschichtlichen kultur zur
trink kultur dieses landes
auch hier wenn man diese straße sieht
kommt man sich vor wie in einem film es
ist eine lange straße mit vielen
restaurants und street food und an
dieser straße sitzen super viele leute
und genießen ihren abend
bei den toiletten hier hast du
eigentlich immer einen kindern der tür
und jedes restaurant hat uns eine
toilette mit dem
56 wir befinden uns hier auf mehr
da wird überall raus
getroffen und erhoffen sich auch
gedruckt und das merkt dass man nicht
nur in korea sondern dabei auch was ist
sanieren sagt man muss sich also den
frittierten
napoli trinken ist einfach nicht hier
[Musik]
juli gibt's wieder auf eine tolle
kulisse
nein noch nicht
[Musik]
das credo sagt kainz gutes so max machen
und er
aber nicht sinnlos
oh ja super
[Musik]
wow
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hätte mir jemand in den letzten zwei
jahren gesagt dass ich nach korea
fliegen werde neue leute kennenlernen
werde und die schönste reise meines
lebens habe dann hätte ich das nicht
geglaubt
[Musik]
es war schon so lange ein traum von mir
dieses land zu sehen und die leute
kennenzulernen die kultur zu erleben und
einfach spaß zu haben und meine
erwartungen wurden einfach übertroffen
und nicht nur die erlebnisse die wir
hatten sondern auch die menschen die wir
kennen gelernt haben haben diesen trip
einfach zu etwas ganz besonderem
das ganze team von jupp oder sind die
nettesten menschen die ich kennenlernen
durfte und wir hatten eine so gute zeit
zusammen dass ich hoffe dass es nicht
unser letztes mal war und falls ihr euch
jetzt fragen und südkorea
es soll eine reise wert ist
ich glaube diese bilder sprechen für
sich
[Musik]